vous avez porté plainte guillaume
larrivé à une autre époque à une autre
époque j'aurais proposé ce député assez
obscur d'ailleurs j'aimerais proposer du
halal duels mais j'ai fait beaucoup j'ai
fait beaucoup des scream à l'époque de
sciences po yens vingtaine d'années
voilà malheureusement
malheureusement on peut plus faire de
duke en blanc non mais je trouve ça
lamentable sur le sur le framework of
permettait d'avoir un minimum de
réflexion juridique pour préparer de
manière bien rédiger ce qui ce qui doit
être fait mais au-delà de ça sur le fond
ce que j'ai voulu dénoncer en cet
échange très vif ces espèces de deals
communautariste entre un certain nombre
d'élus socialistes et un certain nombre
de réseaux islamistes
ça c'est une réalité il ya des petits
arrangements communautaire qui doivent
être dénoncés et qui participe de ce qu
elisabeth badinter a appelé très
justement le gaucho islamisme l'islamo
gauchisme
c'est un vrai problème et ça il faut
l'affronter de près cette réalité